nowadays there are so many different
types of video connectors from hdmi
displayport vga DVI thunderbolt and even
USB type-c but what is the difference
between these connectors and which one
should you use
[Music]
welcome to Horus always starting off
with HDMI or high-definition Multimedia
Interface which is the most common cable
out there HDMI is present and pretty
much all monitors and TVs and is often
one of the easiest to use because it
does not have any screws on either side
furthermore it is cheap and it carries
audio for most people this should be
their first choice the only scenario in
which HDMI may be limiting is if you
have a 4k 60-years monitor where video
source only has hdmi 1.4 hdmi 1.4 only
supports up to 30 Hertz at 4k but as
long as you have up-to-date connectors
and cables you should be good to go with
HDMI the only place that HDMI may become
an issue is at high resolutions and high
frame rates playful adoptions are very
slow and lagging in a TV market but
pretty much all monitors nowadays have
it it is in an upward trend due to its
high bandwidth which allows for high
refresh rates and resolutions which is
perfect for gamers DisplayPort 1.2 the
most common type supports up to 144
Hertz at 1080p and up to 60 Hertz at 4k
is played for 1.2 the most common type
supports up to 240 Hertz at 1080p and 60
Hertz at 4k newer standards like 1.3 and
1.4 push it even further reaching 120
and 144 Hertz at 4k display port is a
favorite amongst gamers do to support of
adaptive sync adaptive sync allows for
the monitors refresh rate to adapt to
the frame rate of the PC this is what
g-sync and free sync are all about
DisplayPort also supports daisy chaining
so you have multiple monitors but are
limited on display ports or just want to
reduce the number of long cables then
this is a great option
essentially DisplayPort is the better
version of HDMI but the difference only
comes down if you're using multiple
monitors or using a computer at a high
refresh rate otherwise hdmi and
displayport are pretty much identical
even in price next up we have a DVI
which comes in a handful of variants
including DVI a DVI ad single link and
dual link DVI does support up to 1440p
and 60 Hertz at 1080p but it does not
carry any audio and it's often a hassle
to set up DVI it does support 1440p and
up to 144 Hertz at 1080p however it does
not carry any audio and it can't be a
hassle to plug in long story short in
2019 you really should not get DVI
unless you have to ask for VGA the story
is quite similar vga actually supports
up to 60 Hertz of 1080p often times may
connect the VGA cable to a high
resolution display and the video signal
is being converted from analog to
digital there's a loss of image so again
unless you have to use this try to avoid
it
next up Thunderbolt he had probably
heard about this dude Apple Mac books
but this actually invented by Intel they
want to make a diverse video connector
which would take over HDMI and
DisplayPort due to its versatility for
example you don't just have to connect
displays using Thunderbolt you can also
connect hard drives and SSDs however at
this point in time
it really just isn't that common and
doesn't pose any serious benefits over
HDMI or DisplayPort it can pass audio
and has high refresh rates usually
compared with HDMI but it is not
superior to this play port in turn to
refresh rates finally USB type-c is a
more recent addition to the type of
video outputs available it is often very
useful with laptops
Vica carries video audio and power
however USB type-c does not support
adaptive sink like DisplayPort does USB
type-c is more of a convenience cable
designed to reduce hassle with just one
single cable now that we have covered
all the main connection types which one
should you go for well pretty much what
every one HDMI artist
port is the way to go you speed type-c
may be useful if your monitor supports
it and you're going to be Union often
with a laptop but ask for DisplayPort
versus HDMI go with DisplayPort if you
are using a multiple monitor setup or
even like higher resolutions and refresh
rates however if you are not looking for
anything specific like that and just go
with whichever one is cheaper because
they are pretty much identical but
that's just what I think what do you
guys think do you guys think that
DisplayPort is the future and the HDMI
will slowly die out make sure to comment
down below also if you guys liked this
video and thought it was helpful then
make sure to drop a like and consider
subscribing if you like to see more
videos just like this one but well then
I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
[Music]